oh I shot Santa Claus in the face he's
real and I shot him in the face what not
only did I not think the third one would
be made I didn't think the first one
would be made whilst making it it was a
I guys this is impossible they're not
really gonna we're not really doing this
is just an elaborate prank but indeed it
was a real movie and it really got
released and then it became actually
popular with people on DVD and you know
here we are third one bizarre so the
first thing of the maybe there's a the
wall street protests happening outside
and I'm curious was that already written
in shot before Occupy Wall Street's are
happy yeah yeah I mean obviously are the
financial world has been in turmoil for
a couple of years now but so it was it
was relevant then but it's a stroke of
luck and it's gotten worse wasn't like
working with danny trejo is he an
intimidating father-in-law to have on
said yes uh you know he looks exactly
like danny trejo off camera so so still
scary also likes to walk around
shirtless and he has like you know a lot
of ink it's quite the storyboard so if
he's scary but he's a sweet fellow this
also talk a little bit working with the
mph again is it hard to keep a straight
face around him hey could you have to in
that one uh yeah right he's he's
terrific one of the things he does he's
such a great actor and if you'll notice
in this film I love this he done said
Neil Patrick Harris movie star voice and
then he has like a backstage boys I just
think that's so inventive he's great I
got to dance and you know with Neil in
this one it was so fun dressed up in the
toy soldier costume he's just a he's
just a ninja of comedy